digamos que tengo dos colecciones de
datos distintos y en la primera
colección tenemos los datos 2 2 4 y 4
muy bien en nuestra primera lista de
datos y en la segunda lista tenemos los
siguientes vamos a ponerlo del lado
derecho tenemos el 11
6 y 4 muy bien y lo primero que queremos
ver es si hay un número que nos dé una
medida de lo que podría ser el centro de
los datos y ya hemos visto que una de
esas formas es calculando la media muy
bien entonces veamos para estos datos
cuál es la media para el lado izquierdo
tenemos que la media se calcula como la
suma de todos los datos dividido entre
el número de datos verdad entonces
tenemos 2 más 2 más 4 más 4 dividido
entre 4 muy bien y ahora si intentamos
calcular esto podemos ver que es dos más
dos son cuatro más cuatro son ocho más
cuatro son doce dividido entre cuatro y
doce dividido entre cuatro nos da
exactamente tres muy bien entonces ahora
vamos a tratar de visualizar los datos
vamos a ver si nosotros por ejemplo
ponemos vamos a hacerlo digamos con una
gráfica de puntos
digamos que ahí tenemos un eje
muy bien tenemos nuestro eje y ponemos
por ejemplo no sé aquí a lo mejor el 0 y
el 1
a ponerlo bien el 2 el 3 el 4 y digamos
que llegamos hasta el 5 entonces
podríamos ir acomodando estos datos con
puntos verdad como ya hemos visto en
otros vídeos aquí tenemos un 2 tenemos
otro 2 y tenemos 24 es verdad entonces
tenemos un 4
14 muy bien y ahora observamos que la
media es 3 es decir se encuentra más o
menos bueno más o menos si no se
encuentra exactamente aquí la media
verdad que la media lo podemos ver
justamente como una especie de tendencia
central verdad
qué pasaría si ahora empezamos a
analizar los datos del lado derecho
bueno pensemos primero cuánto vale la
media la media pues nuevamente será la
suma de todos los datos que será uno más
uno más seis más cuatro dividido entre
el número de datos que es cuatro
entonces esto cuánto nos da bueno
tenemos uno más uno son dos más seis son
ocho más cuatro son doce tenemos doce
entre cuatro que como vimos en el
ejemplo anterior esto vale tres así que
vamos a intentar visualizar esto
nuevamente porque hay aquí hay algo
interesante tenemos la misma media
aunque tenemos distintos datos verdad
son bastante distintos estos datos pero
pero hay algo muy particular de estos
datos con respecto a los a los datos
amarillos verdad y esto es lo que vamos
a tratar de visualizar muy bien entonces
pongamos nuevamente
digamos esta recta numérica y bueno
nuestros datos llegan hasta el 6 así que
digamos que este es el 0 y el 1
el 2
3 el 4 el 5 el 6 y digamos que llegamos
hasta el 7 entonces tenemos dos veces el
1 que tenemos aquí él
dos veces y tenemos una vez el 6
tenemos una vez el 6 y tenemos una vez
el 4 entonces lo que observamos hace
unos hace unos momentos es que es la
misma media verdad la media también se
encuentra en el 3 muy bien aquí tenemos
la media así que podríamos pensar que
tenemos el mismo centro pero se ven muy
distintos los datos verdad de hecho
tiene que ver esto con la variabilidad
que es uno de los conceptos importantes
en estadística verdad aquí en este
ejemplo verde los puntos parecen estar
mucho más esparcidos en promedio verdad
y esto es bastante interesante cuando
estamos estudiando estadística no no
sólo tenemos que calcular la media sino
además podríamos buscar una medida de
cómo es la variabilidad de los datos y
para eso vamos a usar el siguiente
concepto que se le conoce como
desviación media absoluta
la desviación media absoluta muy bien
absoluto
muy bien entonces qué es la desviación
media absoluta bueno esencialmente lo
que nos dice es en promedio qué tan
lejos están los puntos de la media que
ya lo mejor este concepto sonará un poco
un poco extravagante o quizás un poco
raro pero en realidad es muy sencillo y
vamos a verlo con estos mismos ejemplos
muy bien entonces para el caso de la
izquierda ok si nosotros calculamos la
desviación absoluta de los datos a la
media en realidad tenemos que hacer por
ejemplo en el primer caso tendríamos que
hacer 2 menos 3 aquí no se está midiendo
la desviación pero si le ponemos el
valor absoluto nos dice la desviación
absoluta muy bien ahora qué pasa con el
segundo caso con el segundo dato perdón
sería 2 menos 3 con valor absoluto
tenemos el tercer dato que es 4 menos 3
con valor absoluto más
4 - 3 verdad el último dato con valor
absoluto entonces cada uno de estos es
una desviación absoluta del dato
o más bien la desviación del dato con
respecto de la media ahora bien como
nosotros queremos una desviación media
absoluta tenemos que hacer el promedio
de todas estas desviaciones que son 44
desviación es verdad entonces si
nosotros ahora si calculamos esto bueno
tenemos que 2 - 3 - 1 pero con valor
absoluto es 12 menos tres es menos uno
con valor absoluto es 14 menos 31 y
cuatro menos 31 ambos pues dan dan lo
mismo con el valor absoluto verdad
entonces si sumamos estos cuatro unos
tenemos 4 entre 4 que es exactamente 1
muy bien entonces lo que podríamos hacer
visualmente es que el 2 lista del 3
verdad
1 aquí tenemos sólo una unidad digamos
un paso para llegar a la media lo mismo
pasa con este dato y también pasa con el
dato digamos cuando cuando cuando
tenemos que el dato vale 4 ok en estos
casos la desviación hacia la media es de
1 verdad eso es visualmente como lo
podemos ver qué pasa con el ejemplo
verde como calculamos la desviación
media absoluta que de hecho podríamos no
sea lo mejor
abreviarlo como de m&a verdad desviación
media absoluta entonces vamos a calcular
la de emea para el caso verde tenemos
que la de m&a pues sería en el primer
caso tenemos 11 menos 3 es la desviación
del primer dato
con respecto a la media el segundo dato
también es 1 entonces tenemos 1 menos 3
el tercer dato es 6 verdad 6 menos 3
verdad tendríamos aquí la desviación y
finalmente
-3 y todo esto nuevamente hay que
dividirlo entre 4 muy bien aquí estamos
haciendo el promedio de todas las
desviaciones absolutas
1 - 3 es menos dos pero con valor
absoluto es 21 menos 13 menos 2 con
valor absoluto es 26 menos 33 así que no
importa el valor absoluto y 4 - 3 es uno
nuevamente no importa el valor absoluto
así que si nosotros hacemos esta suma
tenemos dos más dos son cuatro más tres
son siete más uno son ocho y ocho
dividido entre cuatro nos da dos muy
bien entonces en la desviación media
absoluta es 2 y aquí nuevamente podemos
ver visualmente cómo es que distan de la
media digamos por ejemplo en el primer
caso que tenemos que vale 1 tenemos una
distancia a la media de dos unidades lo
mismo para este dato verdad mientras que
cuando vale 4 tenemos una desviación de
y cuando vale 6 tenemos una desviación
de 3 verdad es justamente lo que tenemos
en este caso
así que en resumen lo que podemos decir
es que la desviación media absoluta para
este caso es 2 verdad este es el
promedio de las desviaciones absolutas
mientras que la desviación media
absoluta en el caso izquierdo es de 1
verdad así que esto tiene bastante
sentido pues en promedio los datos que
tenemos en la derecha se desvían de la
media por dos unidades mientras que del
lado izquierdo
la desviación media absoluta es 1 verdad
así que podemos decir que los datos del
lado derecho están más esparcidos que
los de el lado izquierdo